a little over a week ago a very
interesting conversation took place on
twitter that had to do with the job
market or whether it's a market or a
lottery and what goes into being a
hirable candidate it was started by this
tweet by david webster who wrote i've
been hired for two tenure track jobs and
been on multiple committees sent in more
than 100 job applications and done
multiple interviews here is my thread of
job market advice for early career
academics based on decades of experience
number one
get lucky and he followed this up with
some discussion that helps to make sense
out of this and it is indeed a thread so
here is the next parts of it
number two that's it really the market
is not a meritocracy it is pure chance
the advice threads are well meaning and
can help a limited few but we need to
explode this myth that job seekers are
at fault and would be hired with a few
improvements in their style that myth
harms
three by reinforcing the myth of
meritocracy and pushing job seekers to
do yet more we perpetuate a system that
harms an academic system based on
cruelty and exploitation and false
promises less politely lies it needs to
stop we need a collective labor rights
approach four having trouble getting an
academic job the problem is not you the
solution is not publications or cover
letter help or dressing differently
university searches higher almost at
random making applicants jump through
hoops like performing animals redundant
cruelty rains
five i guess a few things can help if
you want to be one of the lucky few take
anti anxiety meds be willing to destroy
your personal life and relationships
that could sustain you pretend you are
all mind with your body's only job being
to carry your brain around six people
congratulate me for having some academic
success but i have a job through luck i
got one postdoc offer out of grad school
so i took it repeat twice more one offer
one more year in academic work moving no
choices just single offers seven finally
i got lucky and got a tenure track offer
just one not a choice of jobs so i took
it and stayed in academic work always
one offer away from leaving i have a
great academic job now i am privileged
and lucky but that's the point it's all
luck not a meritocracy he went on in a
number of additional follow-ups number
eight none of this is meant to deny the
very real kindness of people who write
job advice threads or serve on hiring
committees just that the problem is
systemic it's not you you are not the
problem a little more follow-up quoting
some other tweets lots of people saying
it better there is lots of individual
kindness out there of course
also a key point apologies for not
saying this as well i was also lucky to
be a white guy through most of this and
i should have added that and then
finally also crucial and yes i am most
of those things a few people in the
replies posting that is now harder for
white men to be hired don't believe that
marginalized people are still
marginalized and so this is quite a lot
of information and argument and points
being made rather sophisticated position
i would say let's look now at some of
the replies which sort out into a number
of different genres so here is some of
the first ones thank you for this i've
been saying this ever since i got a
tenor track job and saw the extent of
chance that was involved having been on
several hiring committees since my
conviction has only been strength inside
that was by pusha lee battery responded
to by tammy petinato
same it's not that the people hired
aren't good it's just that it's
typically a choice between a bunch of
good people and there is so much
randomness in that final choice michael
[ __ ] points out it's really more of a
lottery than a market and this is a very
important point i think we talk about
the job market but there really is a
lottery aspect involved and we're going
to talk about how many different
dimensions it has in just a moment dr j
says been a member of four hiring
committees so far david is absolutely
right here it's all about luck and then
in parentheses and pedigree finally dr
christina wyman a committee chair's
whims moods and personal agenda define
who gets doesn't get the position and is
one of the worst kept secrets of the
academic market i bailed on this
dystopian circus four years ago and
never looked back so those are some
representative responses here then we
get the reply and i won't say guys
because
it's a number of different people right
and it has to do with disciplines so
this one says from diddly links this
might be true in your field but i don't
think this is true across academia
especially in some parts of stem aubry
tower points out this is exceedingly
still true in the step many people spend
years decades even applying to academic
jobs doing post-doc after postdoc
adjuncting for years many retire poor
because they couldn't let go of academia
others give up and go to industry late
in the game and are happy
masahita
shiozawa says it seems your area is
humanities mine is biomedical sciences i
suspect the metrics to evaluate
performance or potential are very
different between the two but i feel the
hiring system is far from random and
does have the ability to identify top
candidates emily sloane pace weighs in
and says love it when the science folks
weigh in to teach the humanists how it
works and you're right the metrics are
different we're competing against
exponentially more people for far fewer
jobs patrick madden says i suspect this
varies by field and my cs experience
computer science that is publication and
selective venues is a big filter we also
look carefully at the niche do we need
someone in that niche or not a bad
interview talk and sink a candidate luck
does play a big part though and matt
goodhouse points out something we're
going to look at in just a bit yet
publication in the venues is also quite
random and not a meritocracy peter
joseph points out moving away from stem
and towards the fine arts same with film
and theater where lucrative industries
promote better resumes headshots
auditioning techniques etc whereas the
best advice is to
go to parties then go to the right
parties or else start your own damn
theater and make your own films so a
little bit of comparison there to other
fields besides the humanities another
criticism made by tara levin through a
number of posts okay so i agree there
are a ton of random factors involved in
the academic job market and luck plays a
big part of the outcomes but i find this
framing profoundly unhelpful it's
unnecessarily disempowering to those who
are already stressed about the
uncertainty of the job market and it
takes all agency for their future out of
their hands there are things you can do
to become a more competitive applicant
there are things you can do as an
applicant to highlight your strengths
the best you can there are ways to
approach the search to make it less
stressful i've highlighted these tips
here previously so while the academic
job market can be inefficient opaque
biased and difficult to navigate all is
not lost real people still get jobs
every year and there are people here who
can help you through the process this
reads more like somebody who's
trying to sell a coaching practice or
something like that i don't know that
this is particularly helpful i don't
think anyone disputes that some people
do get jobs the question is how much you
can
do about that and i don't think
anybody's
disempowering people by telling them
that the job market is arbitrary and
prestige driven here's another uh one
criticizing the thread by dr urska
demsar i have been on many committees in
the last 10 years and this is not the
whole truth yes you need luck you have
for example you have no control on who
else will apply but you also need to be
prepared and show the committee how you
fulfill the criteria if the teaching
demo is awful or you're not able to
explain your research plan no one will
hire you if you don't include a list of
publications in your application you
won't be shortlisted you need both
preparation and luck and this kind of
advice that tells you that it's not you
is not very helpful good news is if it's
your preparation that is the problem
that can be addressed by getting
feedback from your mentors and
practicing get someone who has
interviewing experience to give you a
mock interview with this yes it's about
luck but without this no luck will help
and there's some valid points there but
i i think that there's also a undue
stress on you can do it right
in this
so we get a third interesting line of
suggestions here and
you know some pushback on that so
christopher green says there's actual
advice implicit in this if it is all
just luck then simply send out as many
applications as you are physically
capable of your number is bound to come
up but it is not all luck there's luck
to be sure but it's not sheer randomness
it is often things like saying stuff
about your interests or experience that
has little to do with the formal job
description but happens to connect with
people on the hiring committee now that
is a funny thing to say because that
strikes me as being complete luck
that the things that you randomly say
happen to connect up with the committee
heather krasner says i'm a career
services professional who's advised more
than 9 000 job seekers and advised
hundreds of employers on recruiting
strategy you made your own luck by
applying to 100 positions and not 10 by
taking the jobs by preparing for
interviews it's not random and blah blah
blah retorts in what academic field are
there 100 open tenure track positions in
a given year so you know there's a good
response to somebody who's working
perhaps in a different industry and
doesn't understand the academic job
market daniel s hellman says i'll add a
corollary since it's based on luck
applied to a hundred plus positions or
400 don't hate me yes that's a huge
amount of work submitting more increases
a person's odds of landing one and
respects the conditions of the job
market and then eldritch enbe uh draco
dyke points out when every academic
faculty application requires four to
twelve hours of unpaid labor when one is
applying for non-academic jobs yes you
can just push a goddamn button on
linkedin 100 times and blow a day but
academic applications require letters
syllabi statements and student
evaluations get a grip and i think
that's a
very good response i think a lot of the
people who say oh just just do more
don't understand the amount of work
involved in academic applications
here's a very interesting response that
goes back to the initial thread and kind
of addresses these just do more just do
more it is from la habitazion critic a
to me the most shocking feature i've
seen in most academics is the almost
religious belief in heroic individualism
where any personal consequences are
justified if they lead to academic
success academia mental health issues is
no surprise considering the ideology
sustaining it j.c bagels follows up
saying as a faculty union president i
have spent years trying to de-program my
colleagues most with ostensible tenure
protections from exactly this kind of
self-induced stress and suffering
everybody's a straight a student always
has their hand up can't say
no
moving on we have some initial
discussions about the chance or
luck part so joseph steve says i want to
push back on this a bit it's pure chance
it's hugely up to chance but i also had
a book with the top press and three
articles when i finally landed a job
having those pubs put me in a tier of
applicants where i still needed the
stars to align but it wasn't pure chance
and andal narayan says i don't think the
original poster is right about that
either and a generation ago
nobody needed credentials like that to
get a first tenure track offer
jason dormandy says fair to a certain
point not writing clearly not sending
transcripts not having a field asked for
in the ad not teaching in the date range
not having phd in hand not trained in
required survey areas these are not
about luck and lorna bracewell sums it
up very nicely saying here's how i
explain my job market experience the
degree the publications the networking
the teaching experience the polished app
materials that's all just buying the
lotto ticket from there it's just about
getting lucky before you can't afford to
play anymore so you can do as much
preparation as much publication as much
pressing the flesh as you like but it is
a matter of luck or fortune from that
point on
then we have some people
you know following up and digging into
this
preparation
contacts things so dr avery everhart
says i do think it's a lottery but a
lottery among the exceptionally
qualified to paraphrase thomas biller to
explain this to me and unfortunately a
big piece of the exceptionally part
is where you are coming from
whether that's your phd institution or
current job and this is completely
correct pedigree and where you're
teaching opens the doors for you if
you're from an elite school in ways that
it doesn't if you're from somewhere else
elena says it's definitely included in
the having been lucky thing but don't
overlook nepotism sorry network
especially in academia very true gautam
menon says it's important to remember
this point and it's not made enough when
we council advise applicants in most
cases who makes it assuming the system
isn't outright rigged in favor of
someone is really a matter of luck it's
not a meritocracy yes and many of the
positions that you apply for you can't
be sure while you're applying that they
don't already have a candidate in mind
that the fix isn't already in floor
yannelli says
luck plays of course a huge role but
let's not forget that who gets lucky
highly depends on the people deciding so
this is why diverse selection panels are
so important it's not just a matter of
representation but also of reducing bias
a point that the
original poster made
going on arsenal on khan says agree with
all of this except that the system
selects randomly mostly they select from
institutions deemed prestigious but even
then luck plays a big role
melanated scholar following up on this
yep and sometimes you gotta get real
shiny mit made me glitter in the eyes of
academia well if mit likes her we should
to
write and then dr bradley summer says
the other thing i would add is have an
ivy league degree although that usually
implies a certain amount of luck too
mostly in the form of having rich
parents and or being legacy so yeah luck
and ivy league and these three are
pointing out that prestige is indeed
another factor an arbitrary factor and
often itself does depend on luck if we
go on to the next three feed me
scanlines right on the money lucky to be
born in a place and time be born to
certain parents lucky to meet certain
people during your life lucky you were
in the right place at the right time
everybody works hard not everybody gets
lucky scott cunningham says tell parents
to be lucky when they were growing up we
often underrate the importance of where
you're coming from
sean hagen says i would say knowing the
right people helps but that's also
basically just luck so what we're seeing
here is that luck comprises a lot more
than just a purely random flip the coin
roll the dice hit the random number
generator sort of factor following up on
this dr rebecca rooney says threads
recently on the role of luck in
academia's tenure track job market in
these luck and merit are like alternate
drivers of success like don't believe in
the meritocracy being meritorious isn't
enough you mostly need luck this ignores
a key factor privilege a third important
factor that many others are highlighting
and that the original poster addressed
marina the hydrologist many professors
who made it think they know what it
takes but it's just survivor bias for
every one of them that made it with
those tricks there are a hundred who
didn't racism and sexism are real
barriers to getting an academic job that
are never acknowledged even in this
thread of course he did acknowledge it
in the thread but it's it's quite true
um there are lots of factors that stand
in the way in many fields aaron carrillo
says have white cis-het male
neurotypical non-disabled privilege and
make it clear you will maintain the
status quo
rather cynical there but uh there's
there's some measure of truth to that
depending on what job we're looking at
and what institution kelly wilts says i
applied for the job i have three times
and didn't even get a phone interview
why because senior faculty in the
department had a narrow view of what
they wanted we're trying to hire
research one folks for a regional
teaching university and kept hiring
people who didn't care about teaching a
very very common hiring mistake that
gets made and i've seen it happen myself
in place after place after place those
those research one folks don't stick
around quite frankly uh and then kelly
follows up saying racist and sexist
faculty won't hire anyone who does edi
work for fear of being called on their
behavior to anyone on the market right
now your rejection has little to do with
your qualifications and everything to do
with the senior faculty who should have
retired decades ago and i think that
there is a very important point to that
because
of the financial crisis that started in
the
early aughts a lot of older faculty who
should have retired didn't retire and
their positions you know just got held
onto many of them hanging on for another
decade and controlling the hiring
decisions here's the last one and i
think this is an important point as well
i've seen this happen to many colleagues
carla karen says this is so real my
sister spent 16 years as a visiting
professor than adjunct because she
married a colleague at least she had
health insurance as a faculty spouse but
despite her scholarship teaching and
service for years she was never
considered when they had tenure track
openings dear student responds that's
the weird thing no one looks to
non-tenured to promote to tenure track
the system is broken when you can't
value loyalty and hard work that's
already teaching in your program this
has been a problem for
decades and it's a reversal of how
things
used to be
a long time ago where teaching as an
adjunct would in fact give you a leg up
in applying for a place in
that school except for certain elite
institutions
so that's that's a very important
consideration as well so a lot to say
about this and i think it's great that
people are engaged in open discussion
about these matters a lot of people in
academia or who leave academia suffer
considerably because they
think that the problem is with them when
really it's a chance driven and largely
unfair system it's if it ever was a
meritocracy it isn't anymore and this is
perhaps even more the case at elite
schools where you just look at at the
people that are there many of them are
very smart a lot of them are just
placeholders but happened to
ticked off the right boxes for hiring
committees and i don't think that its
talent pool is different at elite
universities than it is at most other
places so we have a lot of very
interesting points to consider
in this twitter conversation
you